hello and welcome to this video playing
your shake let's see what your shake is
up to I'm highly rated blitz player and
I've told everyone school- form it's not
great let's move that before was
supposed to prevent didn't you see that
now of course he saw it but he may he
just ignored it so I'm actually not sure
maybe I would have to check on d5 with
the pawn
I really never really checked this line
because it just looks so weird to play
d5 but yeah I kind of see the point him
not before is annoying not if Bishop f5
maybe a3 is a very slow move there I
probably should take with the pawn
that's also better for my development
mm-hmm I should take with a pawn ok
anyway it's a bit late now to set crying
over spilt milk or something is that an
expression now that's it's not good him
I have no development him Queen takes is
good
I mean Bishop takes is also not bad but
Queen takes is probably stronger pretty
awful pretty awful this opening here
opening result
hmm 93 even coming here wow what was
that bad Oh disgusting absolutely
disgusting my mom's just a stupid idiot
how much time I spent one second I'm
making the same mistake they all make
playing playing too quickly in critical
positions and it is a critical position
already yeah
great absolutely losing
yeah it's super easy when very strong
bishop am the a porn blah just a total
loss
[Music]
I have to take with the pawn I mean
d-file is not a good move I mean it
really is not but I should think about
it and not just play whatever yeah he
can probably his friends to take and
play play rock t2 of course the trade
winds now but ok everything does they're
the only small hope some opposite
colored bishops ending if he does
something stupid and like King is 796 or
something okay I mean this is this is
not all that easy here maybe maybe I
have some ideas here with the C pawn I
definitely had a worse position than
that earlier it's still pretty bad of
course but I think it was even worse
yeah so what about this is he prepping
my knight or not other than that I
should go 96 or 96 so I got two opposite
colored bishops he allows me to take
that
I'll make sure to later I'm just a
complete [ __ ] here or what
I'm actually too late thank
check
at least them there knowing immediate
promotion a king takes Bishop e6 is
probably a draw he has to take with the
bishop don't know I mean maybe okay King
D 5 or this one okay so C 6 maybe you
can actually just promote and then the
end is good okay my baby ship is also
just hanging at the moment so of course
you can just take the bishop then yeah
yeah I can just take the bishop of
course yeah and they have to do now okay
okay okay okay
white resigns yeah then what an idiotic
game I mean yeah have you just think
just think instead of playing I mean I
was a little bit provoked by 25 because
it just it just isn't it isn't okay
actually it this is this is the reason
actually this is the reason actually not
the capture oh my god
yeah yeah yeah I mean okay this is the
playable position for black like don't
get me wrong and I can I can fire
and you know yeah I just had a total
total brain slip down now this is the
right thing I can I can get into this
position which is a bit better for white
due to space of course yeah it's not the
pawn it's not the pawn this is this is
downright downright terrible just this
is just a very very bad game yeah this
position just just totally sucks Knight
f3 is better yeah whatever
I really morally hating to look at this
I mean maybe maybe this is a bit better
than the game but it's illness doesn't
make much snow no fun
ha and he probably could have done that
a little bit better I'm really not sure
if I thought I mean this you should
never get but maybe yeah this losers I
have to do this first and here I mean
this is something that at least you
can't fight and it was I was coming from
a position which was completely
completely lost this might be lost as
well I mean I'm not saying it isn't but
well it's from the still using that some
home it's the wrong Bishop yeah for the
edge porn but I don't see I don't get to
get this stuff it's probably still a
loss not much to do yeah I'm an idiot in
the opening and opening that's just
terrible
okay guys thanks for watching